seguridad y garantías de no intervención
estas son las dos principales peticiones
que presentó rusia la otan y eeuu para
escalar las tensiones del kremlin con
occidente
washington
washington y sus aliados de la otan
tienen que parar de inmediato sus
acciones hostiles contra nuestro país
incluyendo juegos de guerra no
anunciados encuentros y maniobras
peligrosas de navíos y aviones militares
y poner fin a la absorción militar del
territorio ucraniano el pliego de
peticiones además consta de la demanda
de que no se desplieguen tropas de la
alianza en los territorios que no se
contemplaban en 1997 antes de la
expansión hacia el este de la otan
también le exige renunciar a cualquier
actividad militar en ucrania y le pide
la no ampliación del bloque al mismo
tiempo el kremlin demanda excluir a
ucrania de la otan una propuesta que
haya sido negada por la organización
hemos recibido las recientes propuestas
de rusia somos claros en que cualquier
diálogo con rusia también tendría que
atender las preocupaciones de la otan
sobre las acciones rusas estar basado en
los principios fundamentales y los
documentos de la seguridad europea y
realizarse en consultas con los socios
europeos de la otan como ucrania en
consultation nate spring partners touch
screem la casa blanca dijo que recibió
las propuestas que incluían el pedido de
acabar con el armamento nuclear de ambos
países fuera de sus fronteras y no usar
otros territorios para preparar
ofensivas y afirmó que haber
conversaciones se harán de la mano con
sus socios europeos las propuestas se
dan en medio de una creciente tensión
entre rusia y occidente con la
concentración de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania